buenas tardes efectivamente ella solo va
a hacer dos actos entre la primera y la
segunda vuelta y por qué eligió avignon
porque el departamento en el que se
encuentra la ciudad la bucle es un feudo
de la extrema derecha santiago ello
obtuvo aquí en primera vuelta un 29 por
ciento de los votos frente al presidente
manuel macrón que sólo tuvo 22 por
ciento pero ojo la ciudad de aviñón es
un feudo de la izquierda de la francia
insumisa que tú mencionabas desde alice
melanson que obtuvo acá en la primera
vuelta un 36 como 87 por ciento de los
votos por eso ya está aquí sobre todo
imaginamos para hablarle a ese
electorado que para ella es muy
importante si quiere ganar la
presidencia de france y suponemos que le
va a hablar del que ha sido el tema de
su campaña el tema estrella el poder
adquisitivo pero también de la voz luces
y aquí mariani un antiguo ministro de
nicolas sarkozy de la derecha que se
pasó al partido de marine lepén
agrupación nacional él fue el único que
pasó a la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones regionales del año pasado en
marsella al final terminó perdiendo por
lo tanto también es un guiño a la
derecha que a ella
si quieres ser la próxima presidenta de
francia también